[Music]
hello Facebook people we are in the
Toyota green room because we're talking
about books today you know nobody loves
books more than Oprah Winfrey and this
is her latest book club selection it's
called an American marriage and the
author is what's your name author tre
town tre Jones I can tell you I know
firsthand how Oprah picks her books and
I remember tre when she read this book
she called me up and said I know what
it's gonna be I know what the next book
club selection is I can't wait for you
to read it
she said it's called an American
marriage and that's how I first heard
about you
so tre Jones I always think about
authors find get ideas from their books
from many different places but for you
you got the idea at the mall it's true
you know I was we all go to moles we
most of us don't get ideas about books
well but you can get a lot of things in
the mall there are a lot of people there
but at the time I was on fellowship at
Harvard during research and he just
wasn't clicking right the I want to do
research about mass incarceration and I
was upset but I didn't have a story idea
and I was at the mall just doing a
little retail therapy and I heard a
young couple and they were arguing and
the woman said Roy you know you wouldn't
waited on me for seven years
and I thought she was probably right I
didn't know him but I bet you heard that
sentence what did it mean to you tre and
she said well I you know it who knows in
real life maybe he had been in the
military or something you don't know but
maybe because I was doing this research
already on incarceration I thought oh
has he been you know has he been in
prison mm-hmm and and then when he said
I don't know what you're talking about
this wouldn't have happened to you in
the first place I was like he is talking
about prison but I didn't want them to
stop talking so I didn't turn around I
just kind of listened yeah and my
imagination just went wild but you
didn't go up and talk to them you can't
just go up and talk to people I don't
know I might have if I was an author I
might have said you know I'm doing a
little research we do mind if I asked
you what you're talking about
no love a lover's quarrel and someone
says wait timeout no that would be very
annoying that would be
extremely annoying but you took the guys
name Roy and you made him one of the
characters in the book I did and her
name is celestial yes now how did you
come up with the two names and tell us
about Roy and celestial I borrowed Roy
from the guy in the mall hurry yeah and
also when I was a little girl the boy
across the street whom I adored was
named Roy so I just took that but I came
up with the name celestial about five or
six years ago I visited a book club in
Jacksonville and there was a woman the
mother was Celeste and the daughter was
celestial and I was said that's so
pretty I'm gonna put that in a book and
I saw her when I was at the Savannah
Book Festival she asked me to sign her
book to celestial and I looked up and it
was her and the premise of the book is
about mass incarceration why don't you
want to talk about mass incarceration a
lot of people hear that topic and either
their eyes glaze over they don't want to
hear it or other people say tell me more
why did you want it right about that you
know the idea of the way that prison
intervenes in the life of everyday
people it's just something that I've
been aware of all my life I know there's
this heightened awareness like with the
documentary the 13th and the new Jim
Crow but for many people I grew up in
Atlanta my grandmother lived in
Louisiana which is the prison capital of
the world the idea of just the way that
people ordinary people have to re
situate their lives around incarceration
is just in the in the air and in the
water but I hadn't seen very much
written about the collateral effects so
risen and talked about collateral
effects that's what happens in American
marriage because Roy is accused of a
crime that he did not commit and the
couple Roy and celestial are newlyweds
they've only been married 18 months as
she says I was still combing the rice
from my hair yeah when her husband is
arrested for crimes she knows he didn't
commit did she always believed him yes
she was with him at the time yeah so she
knows he's innocent but I think the real
struggle is whether he's innocent or not
he's still been taken away from her life
and she says a marriage is more than
your heart it's your life and they
aren't sharing their lives
and they have to decide what's next how
to go forward because he's in prison as
you say after 18 months he is sentenced
to prison for how long 12 years and the
question becomes is she going to wait
how is this marriage going to survive so
how did you figure out how you were
gonna navigate that well it just lends
itself to a great storyline you know I
had to be completely open like sometimes
people ask me should she wait and I said
when I write I can't say should I just
have to say will will she wait and just
try to really inhabit her thoughts and
put myself in her shoes because you know
she's a young woman she's an artist her
career is thriving she's been chasing
her dream all this time and her dream
has arrived at her doorstep you know and
what should she do should she abandon
her dream if she does if she supports
her husband I mean it won't help him get
out of prison any faster but is it
gesture and if it's just a gesture is it
meaningful so these are all the
questions and she's a young woman she's
in the private yes and you tell the
story through letters I thought that was
an interesting device to use you tell
the story of letters between the two of
them what was your thought process
behind that well one I write letters and
do you write I do i what do you mean
like you know a piece of paper and a pen
I write things down okay okay all right
I know what a letter is well something I
don't anymore I know what a letter is I
just mean okay Terry got jokes
I just mean under what circumstances do
you write letters well Gail on a piece
of paper I know what a letter e I'm
sorry I just my students have never
heard of this they're like wait what
like on paper okay well I just mean
under what circumstances do you write
well I write my mother a letter every
Sunday so that's c1 yes every Sunday
morning I write a letter to mama I write
letters to friends I write letters to
people like sometimes I'll be on
Facebook or something and I'll see that
someone seems to be struggling and I'll
write them a letter and I'll put it in
the mail why do you do that well for one
it feels like it's a little more
meaningful as it lasts
longer it's like a person and they can
open it read it read it again making the
key said yeah and it takes me a little
longer because part of caring for people
is giving them the gift of time and when
you write a letter you are giving a
person just a little bit more time so
that's why you do that's why you write
letters because it's something that's
personal so that's why you decided to
tell this story through letters I
thought it was interesting the back and
forth but two of them also letters when
all the time Rory's in prison the story
advances through letters and this also
allows we can we see of Roy's life in
prison what he wants his wife to see
which spares us the day-to-day brutality
of experience because when you read
you're experiencing what the characters
are experiencing in prison is brutal and
I did not want to put you as a reader
through a brutal experience so through
his letters you get the emotional truth
of prison without the day-to-day and
there's also a at some point another man
is introduced into the story it was a
longtime friend of hers yes and we have
to see how that's navigated I don't want
to give it away but it is you can I
can't okay we can say love triangle okay
all right I didn't know okay it was a
love triangle which left me wondering
how is this going to turn out did you
know when you introduce a love triangle
how it was going to end I never know how
stories are going to end because well
when I'm writing them it's just like if
you spoil if I were to spoil the book
for a reader the reader wouldn't have
interest in keeping reading that's how I
feel about writing if I know the end I'm
bored so and also if I know the end
you'll feel me as a writer you'll feel
me Amy more there but if I'm really just
following it then one as I have more fun
as a writer because I have that sense of
anticipation like my heart was pounding
in those last fifty pages I didn't know
if everyone was going to make it out
alive yes I mean so you write it you're
telling me that you write it as you go
along yes really but you have some
outline in your head don't you
nope no I really write to see because
also I write to answer a question in my
head and I write to find the answer to
the question and the end of the story it
takes me probably long
- right because I go on a lot of dead
ends but just for me just for my own
growth in artistically exploring
something I need to be an explorer I
can't be following a map
I like this okay page 246 talking about
not knowing where it's going
Roy snaked his hands under my blouse you
love me you know you do and this is the
part I want you to talk about I wouldn't
have answered I wouldn't have answered
even if he hadn't cut my cut off my
breath with a kiss that tasted like
desire streaked through with anger have
you ever had a kiss like that tasted
like desire streaked through with anger
I mean if you had a kiss like that and I
would like telling you well that sounds
like someone that's writing from
experience well you know what the desire
and anger very often can go together and
that's when things get really dangerous
I mean Roy he's back from prison he's he
misses her he's angry with her because
he hasn't seen her in two years and it
is that anger and desire that is
transforming him into someone she almost
doesn't recognize so even when you write
streaked with desire a kiss that tasted
like desire streaked with anger I I
called Oprah at this part I go let me
read you this part you goes I know I
love that line so even when you wrote
this you weren't sure how this this is a
very crucial moment in the story you
didn't know what was gonna happen well
you see the desire is streaked through
with anger or maybe the anger is
streaked through with desire either way
it could go to the left or to the right
which of those will will out yes and
what about that thing that's not
mentioned in that kiss what about love
how did you become a writer um I've
written all my life you know I used when
I was a child I used to write little
books and staple them you know I enjoyed
it
do you remember some of your first
writings do you remember a sentence from
your first remember the title of the
first little book I stapled together it
was called the trip to Mars I had this
idea that I would go to Mars by myself I
wasn't gonna take anybody with me I was
just gonna be like me and my dog and we
were gonna go to Mars and start over
that was my idea and I wrote this little
book and I knew I was about five and
nobody wanted tours nobody wanted to
read my little
yes so you've been writing for a long
time I mean yes and but it wasn't until
I was in college when I met a writer and
she was my teacher her name is pearl
Clegg and she was my teacher and she
really she took me up under that wing I
was like 16 or 17 years old and she
modeled for me the writers life she used
to do this kind of like a performance
space called live at Club zebra and
writers would come and read and she
allowed me to go you know I was underage
and she was a young professor and she
said you can come she says but you can't
you know have any alcohol because you
know you're underage and it could cost
me my job and I was like I was on my
best behavior I wasn't even tempted
because I knew she had given me this
gift of allowing me to see what it was
like to live this artists life in the
city and so I just sat there and I just
watched and I knew what I wanted to do
with my life but she clearly saw
something in you that maybe you didn't
see in yourself
absolutely I did not know that I could
be a writer I knew that I enjoyed
writing but she showed me how to make
writing something to do meaningful work
when I was a child and a young person I
just wrote because I enjoyed it but she
taught me how I can use writing to help
improve the world and to further my own
understanding she helped me she helped
me understand that as a calling not a
hobby calling there is a difference but
then I was reading at one point you
thought maybe I'm gonna give up writing
I don't have it I thought I had run out
I felt like of ideas or the talent or
the would know I I was thinking that
maybe being a writer was like being an
athlete you know you can't do it forever
and when I was having such a hard time
completing this book I thought maybe the
challenge of the conflict between
celestial Roy and Andre I couldn't get
them out I couldn't unravel the knot and
maybe maybe this just was the end for me
and I was just grateful because I had
written three books already and I felt
like so many people wish they could
write one and I've written three and I
was you know doing kind of a gratitude
practice for the books I had been given
and I was willing to release this one
you know what turned you around well one
thing I teach our students and
I always tell them they can't give up
and they have to keep going and would I
be worthy to be their teacher if you're
not following your own advice to them so
I just kept trying a little bit every
day because you know I said I can't
control whether I finish it I can only
control whether I try to finish it and
so I just kept working on it and then I
feel it's almost like filling up a
bucket with an eyedropper you just keep
doing it and then one day the bucket is
always a long time it was a long time I
mean I was stranded fifty pages from the
end for more than a year why was it hard
for you I just think the question of
celestial and her she has Roy her
husband and he has suffered so much
but then there's Andre the boy next door
who loves her and I think just as she
was having a hard time deciding should
she put herself before other people I
think I was wrestling with it as well
when I write me and the characters we we
are together in this struggle yeah and
if I can't figure it out they can't
figure it out I know it's so interesting
because I went back and forth on how it
should end I have to say I think you
ended it really really well I like how
it to you know but I did I went back and
forth back and forth how should this
turn out and you called it an American
marriage why because you had another
title I read I had a number of other
titles okay every give me a couple I'm
so embarrassed okay the first one I
originally was going to call it dear
history because the letters are saying
dear and Roy has this moment when he
says when he was a boy writing in a
journal
dear history here I come or something
like that so I had that one but it was
too stuffy yeah I don't like that one
better than this okay and I rewrote it
and I had a new editor and I wanted to
make sure he read this as a love story
not as like a novelized version of the
new Jim Crow I want him to know this is
a story about people so I gave it kind
of a romancey title I called it this is
how I love you so he would read it to
feel that way and it worked like he read
it as a love story but he said we needed
a title with some more heft you know and
so I came up with an American marriage
and I was just playing with them because
he said oh we can brainstorm and I said
oh we'll call it an American marriage
when you say American and make
things sound important and I said I have
a cat and she's writing memoirs called
American feline it's gonna be huge and
he says oh I like that I do too I was
like an American feline he says no in
American marriage but I didn't like it I
felt like it sounded like it was about
some white people in Connecticut getting
a divorce
and he says why do you think Connecticut
is more American than Atlanta very good
question it was just that I feel like I
lived in Connecticut yeah well good
question how American what was it was
American wasn't it it was very Mary
something about Connecticut if something
about there were two black people there
well see this is why I felt like I
hadn't that I loved I loved the thinking
behind it going but I just feel like as
a black person no one ever says I'm
American even like I'm abroad people say
oh there was an American in the cafe yes
she was black like it's always a
qualified thing and I felt that if I
didn't say black American I wasn't
talking about my characters so I wasn't
gonna do it and I kept trying to come up
with new titles but finally I called
pearl and she says I know it's deep girl
she said it's deep this American thing
but so many people have made so many
sacrifices because to make this your
home that if you want that title you
have every right to it so I called that
at your back and I said what I'm
thinking about it and he said if you
don't like it that's fine he said but I
hear something else in your voice he
said are you afraid to take a big title
like are you afraid that your book can't
support the weight of this big title
clothes there's that gender thing where
you're like no you know I'm just writing
a quiet story I'm not trying to say
anything about America I'm just you know
do you want to make yourself fit in a
small space and he was telling you own
it yeah the American marriage I think
really describes it well he said I
implore you he's a serious guy he says
please accept the title implore good
word and I said okay and then he said
that's good because we've already made
the cover well Bravo let's end with this
because I always loved how Oprah calls
people and what happens on the other end
of that call
because in the magazine we Haber the
book editor is one that found the book
and she sent it to Oprah she loved it
you know she screens all the books she
sent it to Oprah Oprah loved it and so
I'm wondering from your standpoint how
were you called how did that happen on
your and how did you hear well I thought
Lee was calling me to invite me to do
another review or something because
sometimes I do some work for the
magazine mm-hmm and she said call you in
five minutes
I'm calling you in ten minutes all day
and I thought Lee was just like and
worked to all hours of the night but it
looks like almost midnight East Coast
time and then Lee said I'm calling you
in one minute and so she called and well
someone called uh-huh and it was a
blocked call and so I didn't know oh it
was only yeah yeah and I like what calls
yeah I always feel like that person
blocked it for a reason what is it I
don't answer it if it's a blocked call I
don't recognize the number I'm not
answering I think it's mysterious so I
said hello and she says hi this is Oprah
and I was driving I pulled my car over
and she said she wanted to use the book
for the book club and I said yes ma'am
but what she didn't know is while she
was explaining why all these like
panhandlers were tapping on my window
asking for money and I was like shooing
them away and Oprah is talking and I'm
listening to her and the people are just
asked like $2 $1 and I was just trying
to I was trying to frighten them I was
trying to look ferocious you know and
then I just told told Oprah Winfrey how
excited I was and how eager I was and I
feel like and nothing has been the same
no I know she's very excited for you in
the book has been out it's been
announced how's it doing where is it on
the best I saw it in the bestsellers
list where is it it's doing great um
it's on the hardcover the e-book and the
audio book lists it's called American
marriage and this is tre Jones thank you
tre Jeff you this was fun grats thank
you Congrats